you called for quote thorough expert
driven and objective inquiry into the
origins of covet 19. so let me ask is
there a reasonable chance that kovan 19
leaked from a lab
i can't exclude that i think it's fairly
unlikely i wish we had more ability to
be able to ask questions of the chinese
government and
learn more about what kind of records
might have been in the lab that we've
never been able to see
but most likely this was a natural
origin of a virus probably starting in a
bat perhaps traveling through some other
intermediate yet to be identified host
and finding its way into humans
is answering this question within the
realm of science do you think will we
ever know i think we might know if we
find that intermediate host
and there has not yet been a thorough
enough
investigation to say that that's not
going to happen
and remember it takes a while to do this
uh with sars it was 14 years before we
figured out it was the civic cat that
was the intermediate host with mers it
was a little quicker to discover it was
the camel with sarsko v2 there's been
some looking but especially now with
everything really tense between the us
and china if there's looking going on
we're not getting told about it
do you think it's a scientific question
or a political question
it's a scientific question but it has
political implications
so the world is full of scientists that
are working together but in the
political space in the political
political science space
there's tensions
what is it like to do great science in a
time of a pandemic when there's
political tensions it's very unfortunate
pasteur said science knows no one
country
he was right about that my whole career
in genetics especially
as dependent upon international
collaboration between scientists as a
way
to make discoveries get things done
scientists by their nature
like to be involved in international
collaborations the human genome project
for heaven's sake 2 400 scientists in
six countries working together not
worrying who is going to get the credit
giving all the data away i was the
person who was supposed to keep all that
coordinated it was a wonderful
experience
and that included china that was sort of
their first real entry into a big
international
big science kind of project and they did
their part
it's very different now
you